son inauguration se fait attendre depuis
plusieurs semaines le nouveau marché des
clayes-sous-bois situé en face de
l'ancienne halle n'est toujours pas
ouvert alors que les travaux ont débuté
au dernier trimestre 2010 8 et semble
presque terminé une situation qui
interpelle les habitudes en énerver non
pas vraiment mais enfin bon c'est
agaçant quoi ça il ya 100 ans depuis le
temps qu'on attend c'est un peu agaçant
alors c'est inadmissible alors autant de
retard et pour deux dans ce dossier les
maîtres d'oeuvre est pointé du doigt par
la municipalité
je vous donne un exemple très très
précis concernant ce dernier retard dans
le dans le cahier des charges et il
n'avait pas été prévu suffisamment
clairement par le maître d'oeuvre que
sur certaines portes du bâtiment ses
portes soient des portes coupe-feu et
qui est également un sas à l'intérieur
de certaines pièces
voilà ceci a été découvert très très
tardivement d'où le décalage d'ouverture
la municipalité espère maintenant
pouvoir ouvrir cette nouvelle halle dans
la première quinzaine de décembre
la structure est très attendu par les
commerçants ça nous permettra bien sûr
donc de valoriser encore mieux les
produits qui sont issus de notre
territoire et tous les deux les bons
produits que l'on trouve sur les marchés
ça va déjà être plus récent plus plus
moderne
là c'est un marché qui est qu'est vétus
ça va changer tous les atouts les
étalages sa jolie quoi au final le
projet a coûté près de 4,9 millions
d'euros une fois la nouvelle halle
ouverte l'ancien marché sera démolie et
laissera la place à un programme
immobilier de 35 logements